ya estamos familiarizados con el
estadístico he cuadrada si no lo estás
te animo a que revises dos vídeos sobre
este tema hemos hecho algunas pruebas de
hipótesis con el estadístico he cuadrada
e incluso hemos hecho algunas pruebas de
hipótesis con base en tablas de doble
entrada ahora vamos a extender eso al
pensar en una prueba de gi cuadrada para
la asociación entre dos variables
entonces digamos que sospechamos que la
longitud del pie de una persona está
relacionada con la longitud de su mano
sospechamos que estas longitudes no son
independientes bueno podemos hacer una
prueba de hipótesis recuerden que en la
hipótesis nula en una prueba de
hipótesis no suponemos nada nuevo así
que podemos decir que no hay asociación
no hay asociación entre las longitudes
de la mano y el pie otra forma de pensar
en esto es decir que son independientes
lo que estamos haciendo a menudo se le
llama prueba de eje cuadrada para la
independencia y luego nuestra hipótesis
alternativa sería nuestra sospecha de
que hay una asociación
hay una asociación las longitudes del
pie de la mano no son independientes
entonces podemos ir a una población y
tomar una muestra aleatoria digamos que
tomamos una muestra aleatoria de 100
personas y para cada una de esas 100
personas averiguamos y su mano derecha
es más larga si su mano izquierda es más
larga o si son del mismo tamaño y
hacemos lo mismo para sus pies y te
hablamos todos los datos y estos son los
datos que obtuvimos en realidad ahora
vale la pena pensar en esto por un
segundo qué tan diferente es esto de la
prueba de homogeneidad para sí cuadrada
en la prueba de homogeneidad es i
cuadrada muestra mos dos poblaciones
diferentes dos grupos diferentes y vemos
si la distribución de una cierta
variable entre esos grupos diferentes es
la misma
aquí estamos mostrando un solo grupo
pero estamos pensando en dos variables
diferentes para el mismo grupo estamos
pensando en la longitud de los pies y en
la longitud de las manos y lo que
podemos ver aquí es que 11 personas
tienen su mano derecha y su pie derecho
más largos tres personas tienen su mano
derecha más larga y su pie izquierdo más
largo y ocho personas tuvieron su mano
derecha más larga pero sus pies son del
mismo tamaño del mismo modo tenemos
nueve personas con el pie izquierdo y la
mano izquierda más largos pero hay dos
personas con la mano izquierda más larga
y el pie derecho más largo y podemos ver
todos estos datos pero para hacer
nuestra prueba de gi cuadrada decimos
cuál sería el valor esperado de cada uno
de estos datos si suponemos que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera es decir que
no hay asociación entre la longitud de
la mano y la del pie de modo que para
ayudarnos con esto voy a escribir el
total de las columnas aquí y el total de
los renglones aquí y dibuja unas líneas
entonces cuál es el total de personas
que tienen la mano derecha más larga 11
más 3 más 8 es igual a 22 el total de
personas con la mano izquierda más larga
es
29 14 es igual a 25 y el total de
personas que tienen las dos manos del
mismo tamaño es igual a 12 13 más 28 que
es igual a 53 y luego si sumamos esta
columna 22 más 25 es igual a 47 más 53
es igual a 100 sumamos las personas que
tienen el pie derecho más largo 11 más 2
más 12 es igual a 25 las que tienen el
pie izquierdo más largo 3 más 9 13
también es igual a 25 y luego podemos
sumar esto y obtendríamos 50 o podríamos
decir 25 más 25 más que es igual a 100 y
el resultado de 50 ahora para encontrar
estos valores esperados recuerda que
debemos suponer que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera debemos suponer que estas
distribuciones son independientes que la
longitud de los pies y la longitud de
las manos son variables independientes
si son independientes lo cual estamos
suponiendo entonces nuestra mejor
estimación es que el 22 por ciento tiene
la mano derecha más larga y nuestra
mejor estimación es que el 25 por ciento
tiene el pie derecho más largo entonces
de cada 100 esperaríamos que 0.22 x 0.25
x 100 tuvieran el pie derecho y la mano
derecha más largos sólo estoy
multiplicando las probabilidades que es
lo que haríamos si éstas fueran
variables independientes
así que 0.22 por 0.25 es igual a vamos a
ver un cuarto de 22 es igual a 5 y medio
entonces esto va a ser igual a 5.5 ahora
qué número esperarías que tuviera la
mano derecha más larga y el pie
izquierdo más largo esto sería 0.22 x
0.25
x 100 bueno recién calculamos esto sería
5.5
y luego para encontrar el número
esperado que tendría la mano derecha más
larga y los dos pies de la misma
longitud podríamos multiplicar 22 de
cada 100 por 50 de cada 100 por 100 lo
que va a ser igual a la mitad de 22 esto
es 11 y podemos continuar el valor de
aquí sería igual a 0.25 x 0.25
multiplicado por 100 25 x 25 es igual a
625 así que esto es igual a 6.25 este
valor sería 0.25
multiplicado por 0.25
multiplicado por 100 que otra vez es
igual a 6.25 y para el valor que tenemos
aquí hay un par de maneras en que
podemos obtenerlo podemos multiplicar
0.25 por 50% lo que nos da 12.5 o
podríamos decir que esto más esto más
esto es igual a 25 entonces esto sería
12.5 podemos encontrar este valor
esperado porque
5.56 punto 25 más esto es igual a 25 así
que vamos a ver 5.5 6.25 es igual a
11.75
13.25 es igual a 25 lo mismo hacemos acá
esto sería 13.25 porque este es 11.75 +
13.25 es igual a 25 si sumamos estos
números obtenemos
26.5
26.5 más que es igual a 53 bueno es
igual a otros 26.5 ahora que tenemos
todos nuestros valores esperados es un
buen momento para probar nuestras
condiciones la primera condición es que
tomemos una muestra aleatoria
supongamos que lo hicimos la segunda
condición es que el valor esperado para
cualquiera de los datos sea al menos
igual a 5 y podemos ver que todos
nuestros valores esperados son al menos
igual a 5 los datos reales que obtuvimos
no tienen que ser igual a 5 así que está
bien que tengamos un 2 aquí porque el
valor esperado aquí es 5 o mayor y luego
la última condición es la condición de
independencia que ya sea que estemos
mostrando con reemplazo o que nuestro
tamaño de la muestra no sea mayor del
10% de la población
entonces supongamos que eso ocurre
también
suponiendo que cumplimos todas las
condiciones estamos listos para calcular
el estadístico y cuadrada y lo que vamos
a hacer es que para cada punto de datos
vamos a calcular la diferencia entre el
dato y lo esperado 11 menos 5.5 al
cuadrado dividido entre lo esperado
entonces hice este ahora voy a hacer
este más 3 menos 5.5 al cuadrado
dividido entre 5.5 más ahora voy a hacer
este 8 menos 11 al cuadrado dividido
entre 11 y luego voy a hacer este 2 -
6.25 al cuadrado dividido entre 6.25 y
voy a continuar haciendo esto lo voy
hacer para cada uno de estos nueve datos
y ya lo calculé de antemano para ahorrar
un poco de tiempo si hacemos esto para
cada uno de los nueve datos vamos a
obtener que el resultado del estadístico
he cuadrada es igual a
11.942 ahora antes de calcular el valor
p tenemos que pensar en nuestros grados
de libertad tenemos una tabla de 3 x 3
así que una manera de pensar en esto es
el número de renglones menos uno
multiplicado por el número de columnas
menos uno lo cual es igual a 2 por 2 que
es igual a 4 otra forma de pensar en
esto es que si conocemos cuatro de estos
puntos y conocemos los totales podemos
obtener los otros cinco puntos ahora
estamos listos para obtener el valor b y
podemos hacerlo usando una calculadora o
usando una tabla de gy cuadrada pero
digamos que lo calculamos usando una
calculadora y que obtuvimos un valor p
igual a cero punto 0 18 y sólo para
recordar el significado de esto es la
probabilidad de obtener estadístico y
cuadrada al menos así de grande o mayor
y luego hacemos lo que siempre hacemos
con nuestra prueba de hipótesis
comparamos esto con nuestro nivel de
significancia y en realidad tenemos que
establecer nuestro nivel de
significancia desde el principio así que
vamos a suponer que cuando establecimos
nuestras hipótesis dijimos que queríamos
un nivel de significancia igual a 0.05
en realidad tenemos que hacer esto antes
de calcular todo esto y luego comparamos
el valor t con el nivel de significancia
y vemos que este valor p es un poco más
pequeño que el nivel de significancia y
una manera de pensar en esto es que
obtuvimos todos estos valores esperados
suponiendo que la hipótesis nula era
verdadera pero la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado así de extremo o
más extremo es menor que el 2 por ciento
lo cual es menor que nuestro nivel de
significancia y esto nos lleva a
rechazar nuestra hipótesis nula y nos
sugiere que hay una asociación entre la
longitud de las manos y la longitud de
los pies
el próximo vídeo